you can't vote if you're not registered
across the world people have died
fighting for the right to vote we have a
duty which we take very seriously to
ensure that all elections are free fair
and impartial in addition if you're
opening a bank account applying for
credit or a mortgage not being
registered will affect your credit
rating these days you can't do much
without an address and it needs to be
correct the postman emergency services
and lenders all need to know exactly
where you live and they can check that
with us when you buy your house you can
ensure that you're protected by checking
that the property has planning
permission is free from financial burden
is not going to be knocked down or a
road built through the garden will also
tell you whether the property is listed
in a conservation area or they're
protected trees in the garden once
you've moved into your house you may
wish to go and celebrate by going for a
meal in a restaurant with a glass of
wine or go to a pub for a drink and a
dance on your way home grab a take away
before jumping into a taxi to take you
home each of these areas will be
licensed the restaurant the pub the
takeaway and the taxi including its
driver all to ensure the safety and
well-being of you the public